hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slender the eight
pages okay this is the original again
this is the original so I actually
looked up their people I was an idiot
but remember I've only played this twice
so there's a path through the woods a
path that you're supposed to follow and
I see I see got a little map here that
shows it was really obvious if I'd known
it at all if I bothered to look at the
ground I would have seen it so I've got
a little strategy that I think is gonna
work I don't want to hit like the
building and the tankers I don't want to
hit those last so it goes first and then
loop around okay let's go
I got it I know what I'm gonna do okay
so I'm on a path this is path and if I
follow this path I will get to where I
need to go so you take it to the right
it should take me to the big red build
Oh or something
I hate these woods I hate I hate these
woods I hate them I hate these woods
follow the path this is path correct
it's hard to tell really I'm just
assuming it's a little barren than its
path
I think so I think so I think so hey
bacon it was so much I hate him I hate
him I hate him but it's okay cuz I'm
gonna be okay I'm gonna move forward I'm
gonna be better be better be good all
right
so I keep following I'm assuming this is
the path and any second now I have made
a mistake because those didn't look like
the red dildo if I made a mistake please
don't tell me I made a mistake already
oh okay ah I really want to beat this
game I really want to beat I've been
able to beat most of the slender's so
I'm actually gonna go back and do
thorough playthroughs of them all
because I don't want them to beat me oh
don't tell me like I looped around and
now I'm going to lick the rocks or
something I don't know
oh I must have effed up ah I think I
think that's that's a pathway out to the
building because that's big and open so
if I look to the right aha the rocks do
I want to hit those rocks yet though
that's the question one two three four
or five I'm gonna hold off on the rocks
and I'm gonna go out to the tankers I'm
gonna hit the tankers first and then the
building and then the tunnel and then
whoop completely clockwise around so
that I can get everything and absolutely
everything and not miss anything because
I don't want to fail I can do it I can
do this guy's you guys believe in me
right you gonna deliver me you guys
don't believe in me I can tell I can
tell all right
numero 1 yep uh-huh
how about that yep
seems right to me I'm okay with that
thump-thump II and also I read after six
pages you can never ever ever look
behind you ever again because he's
always right there okay so I'm just
gonna go in here
I'm Oh get my page wherever it be check
all the rooms if it's not in here I bug
her out to the tunnel Oh nope chair high
okay not there there are 10 locations
there are eight pages and I do like to
pay homage to the very first slender
game because this is the original this
is the one that started like the whole
spiel all the Slenderman shadow maps all
the everything okay just two more rooms
check high chair easy baby knocked over
send out here then I just get out I go
to the tunnel no I remember
Slendy got me what the hell is going on
up there sure Slendy got me when I just
had two pages last time I played this so
I don't know how that LK doesn't look
like it's in here
fine by me I am perfectly okay with that
so I just walk out to the north here
there should be another path
here haha don't know I printed
oh I sprinted and I'm going into the
woods why am I going into the woods Oh F
me I can't go back out oh no oh my oh oh
no food oh okay I'm headed towards the
tankers again but the the path should
have been it should have been there
screw it I'm gonna go back out to the
rocks cuz I know I can hit the path
there cuz I know where the rocks are oh
man oh god I was not ready for that
god frickin frackin I only have one page
Slendy back Ajo okay so it wasn't it
there it wasn't in the building so that
means the majority of the other places
most likely that one at each one I think
I'm gonna go upper I don't know I think
I'm gonna go okay there are the rocks he
is not letting me go okay
god damn it what the punch [ __ ] you
Lindy yeah oh and 100 101 um - uh oh god
I'm getting in here grab just pretty F
this fu Slendy oh man
Oh can't see anything can't see anything
I'm still in the path though so I just
go out the pass there should be another
path that branches off to the cross
walls walls walls whatever um no not
there
god damn oh man don't tell me I missed
it Wallace pretty please don't tell me
that please do not tell me that it can't
have been that close
it just can't cannot have been maybe
this is it aha
yes ha ha ha ha ha I'm gonna make it I
got two big coup numero two
oh right there Hager I'm on it give it
Jessica oh come on
why oh come on that's not even fair how
is that fair how is that fair
oh you're such an a-hole thank you for
not being home leave me alone are you
feeling me alone not even fair how why
their knee their knee their mother what
about you maybe cuz I was sprinting so
much I might have been it might have
been it okay anyway I'm not gonna miss
the path that leads off to the dildo
this time oh god I hate this game I
think this game is that it that's it
okay that's it that's that's what I'm
looking for and then that's the path I
need to take a frigate if there's a page
here oh god oh man oh man yeah the thing
calls this a silo but I've never seen a
silo that looks like this weird granite
shaped their granite I don't know leave
me alone
I'm pass
only you knew Slendy I want to leave you
alone really badly I want to leave you
alone I do I do
I don't want to play these games but
people out there you all forced me to I
don't even know I don't even know just
hold on hold on to your horses thumb I
don't know if that's straight I'm not
exactly worried about camera placement
right now
okay I'm going up this path to the
building at the building of the tankers
at the tunnel if I can find the stupid
path that goes the tunnel the tunnel
like right there but I don't know
anymore I just don't know I just don't
know let me in give me a page and let me
out cuz my heart can't handle this Nikes
Slendy if you can get me if he was
bobbing up with - he's gonna pop in this
building we just won there's a weird
texture problem I don't know and yes I
do that know that the parsec productions
the guys who made this is making a new
one that's actually uh like uh triple a
gamer double-layer
today it's a well made for these games
oh I know that's coming
I'm not looking forward to it but I know
it's coming I said still free I could
tell I don't know
I don't know I don't know nope
I'm gonna get paranoid it I'm like
there's another room in this building
that I'm not checking maybe wait hang on
let me look down this hallway I think I
know the pages glove who was there come
on
200 come on 337 how could that be
Ben explicable anyone again if anyone
knows what I'm talking about high five
high five I'm just uh keep fidgeting
with the camera cause I know it's not
even moving it like two inches but I'm
just a little all nervous at the moment
okay I swear I'm gonna go crazy that
that's thumping come on
Oh God thank you uh I was about to say
there's not one at the tankers and the
house I would be don't look her thank
you I know how slender man works come on
so actually I'm gonna go go to the rocks
and then if I continue going counter
clockwise
I'll hit everything cuz I already got
the one in the silo
those cross walls Oh even the rocks even
the rocks were a pain even the rocks for
not fun okay he moveth okay moving up
hey movin there they are oh that it is
that it oh is it
ha ha ha ha ha my screen getting fuzzy
who is there he's there he's there he's
there he's there he's there he's there
he's there he's here he's there he's
everywhere
oh man it's just three pages and already
my vision is getting a little hard to
see
okay okay all right all right all right
all right cross wall should be coming up
fairly soon I'm gonna go to the right
side this time see if I can get it first
it's over there probably not it's
probably gonna dick with me be in some
other direction I don't know about huh
is this a bathroom across walls please
tell me it's a bathroom cross walls I
can't even see it yeah oh I sprinted
husband a bad idea bad idea
oh let me see please please please
please
why is he right how how how is he huh Oh
give me give me give me give me give me
out of here
just give me back to that please can I
please path path path where's the path
but the bad oh oh thank you bass thank
you baby
okay it should be just a little hop skip
and a jump to the cutted woods the cut
woods I don't know to the left
somewhere up here pretty soon oh haha
who Sam I don't see him okay I think
this is a clearing oh god he's okay yes
yes yes this is it is it Oh Oh can I
only have four he's already up my ass
okay yo these are the giant pillars of
poo oh okay where is it where is it
hi no no I gotta fight nah nah are you
done good
we're gonna find that no no no no no no
no no where'd it go I'm gonna find it I
gotta find the page is there no page
here
Oh where'd a hell am i okay there there
I don't think there's a paint there I'm
just gonna assume that there is not a
page there oh hey oh this got to be a
page there oh one two three four okay
there's four other places I'm back on
the path sunny go away seriously sunny I
don't want to play today
wherever how about you go in a hole and
die I'd be lovely if you could do that
for me oh no oh no I don't see you where
back page I don't even see him what he's
there help me help you [ __ ] you help me
[Music]
okay I'll follow the path can't see jack
cannot see anything look behind me okay
I'm going to the truck
there's a truck over here always a bad
there's the truck god I cannot say I
can't see it it's like pitch blackness
everywhere oh god there's a truck then
there's bother truck
follow the path follow the path there go
purple
ah this game I hate this game
[Music]
alright okay
I am ahah waiver time huh all right
oh yeah I want to beat it I will maybe
eventually probably beat it but I can't
even get over five I kick it over five
the up fancy maybe this game make it
almost impossible anyway I'm a last time
Oh God
thank you all for watching looking at
taste for more videos that i've done
check out my slender reaction
compilation oh boy
and as always I will see you in the next
video okay bye bye